- Aight, Lamar, you are obviously so good at
so many different things on the field,
but I have to ask. Fill in the blank:
The only way to contain Lamar
Jackson is to...
- You can't.
- You can't. OK.
- The most underrated
position in the NFL is...
- Offensive line. I'm just gonna say
offensive line
because they really don't get a lot of,
um, accolades of, you know, a
lot of public notice from people.
Like, people don't
really give them credit.
- “If I had to, the corner I would
avoid throwing to the most is…"
- Marcus Peters.
- Marcus Peters?
- Mhmm.
- Why him?
What makes him so good?
- Cuz he cheated. Like,
he played receiver, like, back in the day,
so he knows what's going on.
So I really hate throwing to him.
- If Lamar Jackson played in the NBA,
his player comparison would be...
- Bro, I'mma say Russell Westbrook.
- OK. Why? Why Russell Westbrook?
- I don’t know. Because he's so energized.
And, like, people love seeing him.
When he, you know, he take off, he go crazy.
Like, with the dunks. He's explosive. Like, that’s
what you see and that's why it’s Russell Westbrook.
- Could you have been an NBA player
if you worked at it?
- Honestly, yeah.
- Yeah?
- I never tried to play it so, nah. I can dunk and stuff easy.
- [Laughing] OK.
- I can dunk and stuff easy, so. And I can
shoot. I got my lil’ shot or whatever,
but I never took it seriously.
- It seems like there is always, like, a
Patrick Mahomes-Lamar Jackson debate happening.
Does it bother you that
that's always a topic?
- Yeah, that's annoying.
We play football. Two different teams.
Ain’t got nothing to do with each other.
Like, we just play football.
That's it.
- Do you think it’ll ever end?
- Nah.
But I just wanted to say that.
- If you could take one aspect
of his game, what would it be?
- None.
- None? You're like,
"I'm Lamar. I don't need it."
- Yeah. I ain’t tryin' to be him.
- OK.
- I’m my own player.
- If there is one thing—
- No, I'm lying!
I'm lying.
- OK.
- To throw as far as him.
I want that cannon.
He got a cannon arm.
- OK, so you would take Patrick
Mahomes’ arm.
- I'd take that cannon, yeah.
- Tell me about your
friendship with Drake.
What was it like to see him,
you know, have on the 8 in his video?
- It was dope, man.
He hit me up, you know.
He didn't tell me he was gonna
put my jersey,
well, jersey on in the video
or anything like that.
I happened to get tagged by some fan.
Then I ended up seeing it on his page.
It was, it was crazy. I got me some of Drake’s fans
off that, so it was dope.
- [Laughing] OK, now, I'm a big Drake fan, so
I'm not of this belief, but
many people will say that—
- The curse.
- Now you have the Drake curse and
the Madden curse going against you.
What would you say to that?
- Two negatives make a positive.
[Laughing]
- OK. Now, I like that answer.
Two negatives make a positive.
Will Lamar Jackson open
Madden with a 99 overall?
- Oooh, I hope so.
- I hope. I don't even know!
- So you're in the dark?
- I'm in the dark.
Yeah, I hope.
- Should Lamar Jackson have a 99 overall rating?
- I don’t know. It’s up to the EA guys.
I feel I should've had a
better overall last year than it was, so, it’s up to them.
- What do you think you should've
been last year?
- Better than the 76 at the
beginning of the season—
78, whatever I was.
Yo.
- What attributes do you have
that make you a 99 overall?
- It’s whatever Madden feels.
I don't know.
- But if it was up to you?
If it was up to you?
- I'd already been a 99 if
it was up to me.
I don’t know. That's what
I'm trying to tell you.
That's why I'm mad about it.
- [Laughing]
OK, I'm gonna make you the GM.
I'm gonna give you a position and
name some players, and you pick the ones
that would be on your ultimate team,
OK?
All right, I'm gonna name five quarterbacks.
You get to have two
quarterbacks on your team.
You gotta pick two of these
quarterbacks, OK?
- Cool. Cool.
- Michael Vick,
Russell Wilson,
Peyton Manning,
Deshaun Watson,
Patrick Mahomes.
- Damn, that's a hard one.
You just threw me—oh, my God.
All right.
I'm getting Patrick Mahomes
cuz they already got him
99, like,
and I'm getting Michael Vick.
I'm gettin’ them two.
- OK, wide receivers.
You can pick three.
Randy Moss,
DeAndre Hopkins,
Terrell Owens,
Julio Jones.
Michael Thomas.
- Oh, my God.
- OK, so—
- I'm gettin’ Julio Jones,
Terrell Owens and Randy Moss.
- All right, no DeAndre.
- No, I—ah, damn.
That's hard.
I love DeAndre. He wouldn’t
drop shit.
I don't know. Him and Mike,
Mike Thomas. So,
damn.
- Running backs.
You can pick two.
Christian McCaffrey,
Saquon Barkley,
Ezekiel Elliott,
Bo Jackson,
Barry Sanders.
- Damn. Bo Jackson and Barry Sanders.
I'm good.
Bo Jackson and Barry Sanders.
- None of the new guys!
- I can’t give—man, that’s green, but
y’all askin’ me, like—this a super ultimate team
right here. Like, it’s so hard, but
it is what it is.
I'm goin’ old school cuz
they already 99 overalls.
- OK, you can pick one of the new guys.
Christian McCaffrey, Saquon Barkley,
Ezekiel Elliott.
- I’m gonna say—I'm
probably gonna say Christian.
Probably gonna say Christian.
- Christian?
- I’mma say Christian.
- OK.
Well, Lamar, congrats on the
Madden cover.
That's huge.
- Thank you.
- And it's not bad for a running back.
- Not at all.
- Thanks for your time.
- Thank you.
No problem.